[Music]
hello there
fortnight chapter 2 season 7 dropped
today with new characters to discover
with new law to be unveiled
and new areas to explore this is the
series in which we look in detail at the
new locations on the island both big
and small and try to link them to the
story so if you've tickled the like
button
had my creator code smashed in your face
there you go
and sat your butt down for ten minutes
let's do this come on season seven
what secrets do you hold
[Music]
so the zero point power did in fact
summon another entity to the island
just like lara croft tarana and jonesy
the first told us
the alien invasion is real the first
thing we did was take the zero
the first thing they did was take the
zero point away using tech we don't
understand
leaving the central island looking like
this it's the opposite of an island this
season it's a soggy wet hole in the
ground
pieces of the spire have been thrown
everywhere i wonder if the zero point
will ever return
and more importantly is the foundation
in that water
he landed in water somewhere on the
island after being broken free
but i don't know where let me know if
you see anything i hope he's the hidden
skin this season
the explosion caused by that alien laser
has left shards of the spire scattered
around the island
which seemed to be harnessing the power
of the alien homeworld
new plant life new purple colors and
there's a strange sound when you stand
near them
oh and also be sure to look up the alien
ship
ain't going anywhere soon i'm gonna call
this the mother ship
because it's about as big as your mum i
promise that is the last mum joke i will
do this season
hold up a minute we have law right here
look at the mothership
look at those aperture doors we've seen
those before
think back to chapter one and the
mysterious vault look
it all makes sense a buried ufo was
under the island all along
okay i'll uh chill out with the theories
let me think about this one
let's keep going with map changes today
the biggest change on the map can be
found over at the former coliseum which
became a ruined farm last season
right now things have seemingly returned
to the good old days of season one
but oh no there's so much more hidden
here it's mind-blowing
this place is the secret headquarters of
io
and their commanding officer dr sloan
the grain silo
is actually a secret telescope and the
barn has a hatch
which will likely be more important
later in the season going under here
right now and we are able to see into
io's underground facility it's been two
seasons since we've been down here
and there's way more to discover this
time around dr sloane guards this spot
and uses a multiplication doppelganger
ability to turn one person
into many i guess i oh aren't on our
side then
i honestly thought they were becoming
the good guys this season there's a
shooting range down here there's
research
and analysis on things i'll never
understand io have now upgraded enough
that they can start using their own logo
on their paperwork
oh a new artwork too this must be
sloan's office
and she seems very egotistical i like
her already
going back overground to the main house
and have a look in the kitchen
firstly is that meowso's cat food i
wonder if he's returning or maybe aliens
just like
cat food but that's not the thing i want
to show you turn around
another whiteboard in fortnite but this
one has identifiable images
the new joey skin with a question mark
next to a silhouetted character
then an alien ship and another sign with
another question mark
i have zero idea what this means but if
you do sound off in the comments and
gloat about how much fortnite you know
there's another room to discover back in
the underground facility
feast your eyes on this that's rick and
marty writes
it looks like they've been contracted by
io to help out
kinda like how jonesy recruited the
hunters a few seasons back
rick and morty are known for selling out
for any product anyone wants to pay them
to promote
yeah uh this is the playstation 5. it's
really fast yeah yeah they really wanted
you to mention the speed that was really
important
yeah it's like the playstation 5 is
pretty cool all right we're done go play
ps5
once again i have zero clue what these
images mean but for extra context
look at the table nearby eels i need to
watch more rick and morty to understand
this
so io are back on the island although
their secret facility remains hidden
from the invaders
they've also set up guard patrols at new
locations
huge satellite dishes have been erected
overnight
to study the alien invasion and protect
the island
their loot caches can once again be
found like in the old days of season two
and look at this
there's no i o vehicles with a logo on
the side
they have new weapons and yeah i suck
with the new weapons
and there's six more of these locations
one across the valley from the weather
station
one in the swamp one by the castle ruins
one of the strongholds
one by our lord and savior graham the
gnome and one by the lake house
you know the place with the tiny chair
hang on is that tiny chair even tinier
a tiny tiny chair now
now over to sweaty sands hang on it's
now called believe a beach
it's where all the suns of beaches go i
said beaches youtube
this spot is now the permanent home of
those who feel the aliens
are really good guys and peace and love
is the way to go
the last time i saw something like this
was in the movie independence day
and that went well for them
[Music]
it's not like that's gonna happen again
hold up there's literally a target
on the building roof oh gosh this place
is going through a little renovation
right now
while the party is in full flow the
boardwalk is being repainted for this
occasion and by the looks of this
vehicle here
a new construction is coming very soon
on the beach are some sand sculptors
which are quite impressive if i saw
these in real life
but what the heck is going on with the
basketball court
they're changing it again any guesses
what this will become
i'm sure you've noticed the blue smoke
signals around the island these shows
where io have commandeered a spaceship
they are calling in backup but these are
the easiest places to grab new vehicles
and then go crazy throwing things around
on my journeys i went back over to the
bat shed in the swamp
and i have bad news although the
building is still here
batman stuff has gone no more batarangs
no more whiteboard of clues
no more llama floaty bad times batman
fans
luckily he's already out of the loop
watch my series if that doesn't make any
sense
while we're down here at the swamp
there's a new npc to chat to
the swamp stalker who has set up a new
life here
growing crops in the wasteland it isn't
much but i salute her for trying
while i was looking for changes at lazy
lake i was rudely interrupted by aliens
and yated over to hot watch
i thought this was an omen but no
there's no change here my friends
but one day that crane will release its
haul and hutwatch 3.0
will be born one day she shall return i
ventured over to the redacted bunker
expecting to find nothing because
nothing ever happened there
but check this new artwork graffiti
opposing i o and embracing the aliens is
donned upon the walls
and now i'm not sure who the bad guys
are is it io or the aliens
maybe both sloane looks like she was
fighting to save the island but i don't
get the feeling it's with good
intentions
oh and the fake vault door for tiantina
is now gone again
rip while we're talking about alien
graffiti there's more on the old dam
turbine
different artwork but the same message
some people are pro-alien
some people are not here's a cool update
back in season three when the map was
flooded we started to see seaweed on dry
land
it was all cleared away but a few pieces
remained
one of these was hanging at the entrance
to steamy stacks
well i know this is really important to
you someone
is finally on cleanup duty at that
location
when i saw this i knew this was the main
update of the week
thanks to luke on my discord for finding
this one first another returner is
bunker jonesy who is still on the island
and still going with his conspiracy
theories
he's in the house at the very bottom of
the island and here you'll find his
research
what's cool about this is that the
replay file shows the updated version
before it's activated
in game this could be a one week wonder
or this could be the start of something
which really breaks down the law
of this season of fortnite i can't wait
to find out more
before we go it's time to predict the
next fortnight event
i'm thinking we somehow blow up the
mothership with some sort of bomb
as everyone pilots a spaceship dressed
as superman
and that's the weirdest thing i've ever
said in my life let me know your
predictions
so there we have it the updated map and
all its shiny new bits what did i miss
here's a bunch of legends who used my
code at the end of last season
thank you very much be sure to send me a
dm on twitter if you want to be named
like the sexy monkey fluffers right here
i'm adam you're awesome i'm going to
find easter eggs see you soon